well as the weather warms up places like
lake mead are sure to be busy and of
course safety is on everyone's mind
that's right probably want to avoid it
for sunday with those windy days but we
did send madison kimbrough to the lake
today to get the do's and don'ts out on
the water she also spoke to some
beachgoers to see how they stay prepared
here at boulder beach safety is key
whether it's having the proper gear like
a life jacket or making sure you have
people around you while in the water we
spoke to those that say they aren't
taking any chances
families from all over are expected to
gather here at lake mead for mother's
day weekend here's a tip leave the pool
toys at home they can easily fly away
especially with the wind expected for
this weekend also make sure to wear
bright or reflective colors to make it
easy for people and other boaters to see
you while swimming as for boaters like
john lano from minnesota he says being
respectful of other riders on the water
makes all the difference we have tons of
boats and so a lot even if even though
we have a lot
people don't have boating etiquette
so there's boats a lot like really close
together so they're you know creating
huge waves for each other and kind of
you know an unstable situation
especially if you get alcohol involved
another thing to be aware of making sure
your boat is fully equipped so it can
run properly and you're not left
stranded also plan ahead as to what ramp
you want to take now the wind is
expected to be strong this weekend so a
good tip would be to not bring many
items to keep track of just the
essentials to make it as easy a trip as
possible reporting near lake mead
madison kimbrough live local now